the north las vegas police department is
reaching out to build better
relationships with the community they
serve
its community outreach unit held a
public forum earlier today at the mom
museum
madison kimbrough has more on today's
event yes it's a fairly new unit that's
only been active for about two years the
community outreach unit is looking to
build trust
among its residents and businesses
around town officers discuss several of
their community-based programs such as
their police athletic league program
that works with the youth along with
their community cam program which is
designed to take advantage of the
abundance of video surveillance systems
at homes and businesses across north las
vegas to help reduce
crime north las vegas officer caitlin
ebert explains
why the cop unit is so vital to our area
there's a lot of
misunderstanding and misinformation
about what a police department does
or you know how they can help how they
couldn't help kind of thing between the
community
and that just kind of bridges that gap
and gives them the information that they
need
and also introduces them to their police
officers on a
more one-on-one level the four officer
unit also focuses on the homelessness
crisis in north las vegas
and this is just one of several events
the north las vegas police department is
hosting to get better acquainted
within the community reporting in las
vegas madison kimbrough 8 news now